let's suppose you finish the because you
had this thing where you want to finish
something and I think that's great but
let's suppose you finish it and then
eventually you go back to it you're like
I'm not really into it do you just leave
it alone but the fact that you finished
it was what was mainly important to you
I often I'll always want to get it to a
point where I can show it to other
people like I've never written anything
I've never done a first draft of
anything had been like yeah like I'm
glad I wrote this but I'm never gonna
show it to anyone because I feel like
you never know when you're gonna meet a
person who wants to do the exact thing
that you had written five years ago so I
always want to get a script to the place
where I would feel comfortable showing
it to someone else if it ever came up
like I don't show it to people but I
would show it like I would read it I
would be happy with a Joe it's like my
wife just to make sure it makes sense
and help me look for typos and then I'm
happy to put it on a shelf and never
show it to anybody unless one day I'm at
a meeting one day I'm at a barbecue and
someone's like yeah I'm a producer I uh
my brother owns a furniture store in
Arizona and I'd love I can get two free
location and I have half a million
dollars and if I can find a movie set in
a furniture store
I can shoot there and that's when I'm
able to say funny I have a thriller that
I wrote setting a furniture store five
years ago no one's ever seen it
no one's ever written it I just wrote it
because I wanted to write it it's like a
story I want to tell but I was very
aware that there's no market for half a
million dollar furniture store movies
but then who knows happy time murders
you know dee Robertson and I came up
with these characters came up with a
story I wrote the script we try to get a
maid for fun we just want to do it for
fun like it didn't happen
put it on the shelf years later we
weren't doing anything with it it was
just sitting on the shelf the virtual
shelf of my computer my agent calls me
he says hey the Jim Henson Company
called me because they're starting a new
division called Henson alternative and
they're looking to do adult oriented
puppet stuff
and they wanted to do they called me
basically like we want to develop an
r-rated puppet movie do you have any
writers who you think would be good fit
to do that and my agent said well
actually I have a client who already
wrote an r-rated puppet movie it's
called a happy time murderers he wrote
it like five years ago and they're like
what so he sent it over and they read it
they're like oh yeah great let's do this
this is exactly what we wanted but we
had already done it just for fun so
that's always been my my method it's
just like I write stuff for fun that I
like and then I put it on the shelf and
maybe one day it'll come up in
conversation and someone will want to
make it who knows what makes it in our
rating well what are these puppets doing
that are so that's so adult oriented
they they're it's sex drugs violence
rock and roll the puppets are doing
everything that people do in their
everyday life but we're finally seeing
what the puppets do behind closed doors
what the puppets do in the streets have
the puppets actually talk to each other
you know I often even you know I often
have I've written a bunch of family
stuff and I've been written a bunch of
PG movies but I've also like well like
the movies I've directed have always
been are and they're always filled with
cursing and you know adult themes and
people have asked me like well why do
you why do you have these characters
like cursing all the time and I'm like
because that's how people talk like my
friends when we're hanging out that's
how we talk you know and when you want
to make a movie about a certain kind of
person like they curse a lot like they
drop f-bombs or this is how they talk to
each other and when we set out to make a
movie about the actual like what if
there wasn't actually a world where
puppets and humans coexisted with each
other and the puppets were like this
underclass of society that were you know
sugar addicts and like living on the
streets and like we're this underclass
like they would actually it would be
pretty rough like and they would talk to
each other in pretty rough ways and it
would be it would be really interesting
to explore and the thing about the funny
thing about r-rated comedies is that
there's a lot of movies you see there's
this very fine line between pg-13 and
r-right
and so it's very easy to take a script
and be like why don't we just make this
pg-13 all you gotta do is cut some pet
bones out of it but but if you are gonna
commit to making an r-rated movie a lot
of times studios or production companies
will say if this is gonna be our let's
make it our like let's go for it you
know like because why not like we've
already committed to appealing to a
certain kind of audience that wants to
see an r-rated comedy and we've
alienated anyone under the age of 60 and
who can't go see it unless they're with
a parent or guardian so we might as well
go for it you know like there's no point
in making an r-rated comedy that's gonna
have like one or two f-bombs and that's
why it's are like why like let's just go
for and get nuts and like let's show the
sordid private lives of puppets and all
the shenanigans they get up to
you